Xavier Nagara vous êtes un habitué des
dossiers de terrorisme et à ce titre
vous avez été amené à plaider aux côtés
de la défense dans le procès des
attentats du Bataclan vous étiez le
conseil de Mohamed Amri l'homme qui a
ramené Sala Abdeslam en Belgique la nuit
des attentats autant dire que aux yeux
de l'opinion vous étiez du côté des
avocats du mal Emmanuel Carrère qui est
suivi le procès affirme que pour être de
ce côté-là du bon il faut aimer se
battre vous êtes un pugiliste se battre
oui
d'une certaine manière
le combat il est pas que dans la
violence sur la décennie terrorisme je
suis intervenu sur plusieurs dossiers et
j'ai appris
j'ai appris à défendre dans ces dossiers
là c'est des défenses qui sont pas
communes qui sont pas comme dans tous
les dossiers de droits communs parce que
au final la réponse personne ne l'a
ni le juge ni le procureur ni l'avocat
quand on touche aux intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation
on peut pas se positionner de la même
manière on doit y aller avec beaucoup de
distance beaucoup de mesures beaucoup
d'humilité je pense
et donc moi j'ai fait le choix en
montant ce sur ce procès là de ne pas y
aller avec de
la même la même violence que dans
d'autres dossiers
par stratégie aussi pour celui que je
défendais mais aussi par respect pour
ceux qui qui était assis dans cette
salle on voit ces planches qui ont été
publiées dans les hors-séries de Charlie
Hebdo être avocat dans ce genre
d'affaires des clariez-vous comprend une
dimension à la fois idéologique et
intellectuelle particulière laquelle
intellectuelle parce que c'est une
infraction particulière l'association de
malfaiteurs dans le box vous voyez il y
a plein de gens spectre très différents
selon qu'on se situe du côté droit du
côté de salade d'Islam ces personnes
étaient renvoyées pour des assassinats
en lien avec une entreprise terroriste
il y en a certains qui sont poursuits
pour des associations de malfaiteurs
terroristes c'est une défense qui pousse
à la réflexion parce qu'on connaît ce
qu'on sait ce que c'est qu'un viol on
sait ce que c'est qu'un meurtre on sait
ce que c'est qu'un vol c'est facile à
comprendre on s'est beaucoup moins ce
que c'est qu'une association malfaiteurs
et c'est une une infraction qui est en
perpétuelle évolution et qui a si vous
voulez pousser
par des querelles entre les différentes
personnalités les procureurs les avocats
les magistrats
qui a poussé à réfléchir et à construire
cette matière dans le temps donc c'est
en ça qu'elle a une dimension
intellectuelle la dimension idéologique
c'est que il y a des crimes et des
délits qui sont en lien avec le matériel
avec la matière il y en a qui sont en
lien avec l'argent
il y en a qui sont en lien avec les
mœurs là on est en lien avec l'idéologie
c'était que les crimes sont commis au
nom d'une idéologie et on ne peut pas
rentrer dans ce dans cette matière sans
prendre en considération cela et essayer
de comprendre les mécanismes qui
poussent des individus à commettre
l'irréparable donc il faut aussi avoir
une connaissance sur ce qu'est cette
idéologie alors justement qu'avez-vous
appris au sortir de ce marathon
judiciaire ce procès a-t-il permis
d'avancer sur la compréhension des
mécanismes de radicalisation et sur le
terrain de la réflexion juridique je
crois qu'il y a une avancée considérable
grâce à ce procès c'est que on est tous
d'accord pour se dire qu'on y comprend
rien la radicalisation et que finalement
c'est pas ce qui est de plus important
dans la poursuite ou la défense de ces
individus ça participe pas de la
réalisation de la caractérisation de
l'infraction parce qu'il est le plus
important
c'est le droit c'est la manière dont
c'est la traduction juridique d'un
comportement
il y a plein de gens qui ont été
poursuivis dans des dossiers de
terrorisme qui ne faisaient pas partie
de la djiadosphère qui ont été des
copains éloignés qui ont donné un coup
de main sans l'occurrence comme vous
défendiez pour lequel je croyais
fortement à son innocence
sous le prisme de l'association de
malfaiteurs terroristes il y a plein de
gens qui sont poursuivius radicalisés et
qui ne l'ont jamais été et qui ne le
seront jamais et parce que finalement
l'indiquer les actions c'est quelque
chose d'accessoire à tout cela la
question elle est un petit peu plus
subtile c'est que vous ne pouvez ne pas
être radiqué radicalisez vous-même mais
venir en aide à quelqu'un on ne pouvant
ignorer ça radicalisation à lui et là ça
devient toute la question du procès en
quoi défendre ces hommes là est une
façon de lutter contre le terrorisme je
pense que encore une fois pour répéter
ce que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure on
a tous une responsabilité très
importante en qualité d'auxiliaire de
justice auxiliaire de justice c'est une
manière de dire qu'il y a pas les juges
d'un côté les avocats les procure on que
tous la même robe d'abord chaque
personne apporte des réponses à des
questionnements qui permettent de
comprendre mieux le phénomène dans son
intégralité je pense et puis et puis
surtout parce que ce que cherche les
terroristes et détruire l'état de droit
et au centre de l'État de droit il y a
le processus judiciaire et ce processus
judiciaire existe doit exister de la
même manière qu'il existait avant que
les les fondements de notre notre
société ne tremble à cause du terrorisme
et c'est une manière de résister le
procès tel qu'il est organisé
aujourd'hui avec les temps de parole les
règles procédurales alors après il faut
qu'elle soit respectée évidemment et ça
c'est une vraie question
et bien
cette résistance là c'est une résistance
face au terrorisme et donc parce que je
suis un acteur du procès en tant
qu'avocat de la défense j'ai ma place
sur les bancs je participe au maintien
et à cette résistance au maintien du
processus judiciaire et donc c'est une
manière de lutter contre le terrorisme
qui veut faire flancher tout cela
pourriez-vous dire que était celui de
votre vie oui d'une certaine manière par
son ampleur
par les douleurs
de chaque côté de la barre et puis parce
que il me permet aussi moi de tourner
une certaine manière une page avec une
une avec une décennie qui vient de voilà
qui vient de s'achever
je j'ai décidé de lever un peu le pied
sur cette matière sur cette matière là
et donc c'est une manière aussi pour moi
de de passer aussi à être autre chose
j'avais besoin de de d'un événement et
quel meilleur événement que celui-ci
dis-moi
je souhaite que ça n'arrive plus jamais
évidemment parce que ça voudrait dire
que quelque chose de terrible nous est
arrivé à nouveau
au cours de ces 10 mois ce que vous avez
reçu des lettres d'insultes des menaces
de morts ce que l'opinion publique
confond souvent
des avocats à leurs clients
des soupçonnes de Queen je crois que ce
procès cette préparation de la manière
dont tout ça a été très anticipé la
communication qui a été celle de mes
confrères
en amont de ce procès a permis aussi je
pense et ça c'est la première chose
les gens s'intéressent à notre fonction
et les gens comprennent que nous
participons à un processus donc vous
diriez que ce procès a contribué à la
compréhension du rôle des avocats la
défense oui qui faisait un peu des
diabolisé en tout cas moi ça a été mon
objectif dans la manière dont j'ai
communiqué la manière dont je me suis
rapproché Arthur des nouveaux victimes
survivants et je et puis aussi peut-être
qu'il y a quelque chose de très lié à ce
procès là c'est que c'est les
terroristes on
ils ont touché une jeunesse intelligente
ils ont touché une jeunesse qui avait du
recul et ils se sont touché une jeunesse
qui qui était capable de comprendre vous
savez quand vous êtes sur les bancs de
la défense moi j'étais tout près de la
cour donc j'étais à côté de la barre et
on a vu défiler ses victimes pendant 5
semaines quand elle venait souvent on
entendait ils nous regardait avec
d'abord un regard de défiance mais à la
fin de leur déposition c'était ouais
défendez-les
défendez-les c'est aussi pour nous que
vous les défendez
ça c'est formidable c'est formidable moi
ça m'a ça a changé complètement mon
regard sur sur mon métier et sur alors
justement c'était un procès hors norme
de par son envergure le nombre de
victimes la charge émotionnelle et
symbolique et bien sûr la couverture
médiatique ce procès historique donc
a-t-il impacté ou en tout cas modifié
votre façon de plaider oui
la façon d'abord de et je sais que c'est
et je sais j'ai conscience que c'est
critiqué par un certain nombre de mes
confrères c'est-à-dire j'ai perdu
volontairement en agressivité ça veut
pas dire que je je que mes arguments
sont sont moins forts que je l'utilise
je les utilise en tout cas j'essaie de
les utiliser mieux en humanité alors ce
serait peut-être prétention prétentieux
de de moi-même mais quand je parle à des
à des acteurs judiciaires je parle à une
cour d'assise dans cette matière là
j'évite d'abord de de leur montrer ou
d'essayer de leur montrer que je connais
mieux le droit que ça c'est c'est une
catastrophe c'est ce que vous faisiez
auparavant ouais parce que c'est un
souci la jeunesse c'est l'insouciance
c'est c'est quelque chose de très
égotique quelque chose de très égocentré
en maturité au travers je pense que il
faut surtout faire comprendre que je
n'ai pas plus la solution que la
journaliste de France Inter Charlotte
Pierret vous a proposé d'échanger vos
impressions à vif tout au long du procès
via des notes vocales avec elle et
Arthur des nouveaux parties civils ce
dialogue entre un surveillant du
Bataclan une journée liste et à donner
cette étrange et magnifique journal de
bord qui a été publié mais c'était
d'abord des messages vocaux que vous
laissiez sur un répondeur on l'écoute on
est le 20 juin il est
8h53 je suis en train de partir au
palais de justice
j'avais envie de vous dire que j'en
pouvais plus vraiment de cette audience
c'est que je commençais à avoir une
forme de rejet
de
d'overdose ouais d'overdose c'est très
bizarre comme sentiment sentiment comme
si tu bouffais
trop de compote
tu vois bah forcément mon autre ça dit
que
même si j'adore la compote je vous
embrasse
le 20 juin vous disiez même ressentir du
dégoût c'est fort les
dans cet été très très très très
compliqué
c'est tellement long enfin je veux dire
on n'est pas préparé à ça un procès
c'est c'est aller 2 3 semaines aux
assises parfois même moins mais dis-moi
on n'est pas préparé à ça et puis voir
les mêmes personnes ouais
toujours la même personne voir les mêmes
les mêmes
[Musique]
les mêmes angoisses
les mêmes déceptions parce que on s'est
battu j'ai approfond respect pour
chacune des personnes qui ont composé ce
procès mais on s'est ressenti blessé
dans la défense on a on s'est senti
l'aisé parfois on s'est senti
déséquilibré j'estimer aujourd'hui que
ce procès n'a pas été conforme au droit
si avec le recul je je
comprends
qu'il y ait eu des moments de
déséquilibre mais je n'irai pas moi
jusqu'à dire que c'est un scandale
c'est une question très complexe parce
que ça nous met aussi en porte à
fourrure d'opposition avec nos confrères
on était une trentaine d'avocats de la
défense et c'est pareil c'est assez
inédit si vous voulez on n'est pas tous
d'accord sur la manière dont se font les
choses il y a un moment où on a tous été
d'accord et sans se
concerter les uns les autres on sait
tous levés d'un coup et on est parti
après
les gens les avocats le vivent avec leur
expérience leur souffrance leur douleur
lors des contentement leur
positionnement politique
peut-être avec du recul que je suis
moins combatif dans cette matière parce
que ça fait 10 ans et que c'est un peu
la culture de l'échec le terreau on perd
et les gens doivent être contents de se
la repère généralement on perd en
terreau c'est rare il y a pas
d'acquittement il y a peu d'acquittement
donc on perd et peut-être que c'est
aussi un essoufflement de ma part
de flancher est-ce que comme la journée
de France Inter ils étaient arrivés
d'activer la cellule psy et mise en
place pendant le procès vous n'avez pas
eu recours
non moi ma cellucci c'était une
bouteille de whisky à la maison j'ai pas
de difficulté à le dire c'est aussi on
sait que ça ronge ce métier il faut être
costaud pour pour encaisser toutes ces
souffrances et puis rester le même le
lendemain donc quand on rentre le soir
si on n'est pas fort qu'on a pas
quelqu'un qui vous a qui nous attend à
la maison on va ouvrir la cellule psy
avec une bouteille de d'alcool mais je
sais pas si vous vous rendez enfin si on
peut se rendre compte de l'horreur
absolue c'est à dire que encore
contrairement à notre posé ils ont été
lights sur la diffusion de certaines
choses
mais enfin
qui est mort au Bataclan et qu'on vous
montre la scène la scène de crime
les
traces de sang dans la fosse et les
amours tellement de corps
des membres déchiquetés comment est-ce
que vous pouvez rester
normal après tout cela enfin je veux
dire
certains ont
fermé les coutisses on dit moi mon rôle
c'est avocat je rentre chez moi il se
passait rien
moi même après 10 ans d'expérience dans
cette matière bon ben je j'en suis pas
sorti un DM parlons de votre parcours
maître negaraz Jawad Bendaoud dit le
genre de daesh le terroriste Carlos
l'humoriste Dieudonné ou le
narcotrafiquant robertoz ont déjà fait
appel à votre éloquence vous avez
également défendu nombre de radicalisés
de retours de Cyril et les revenants
comme on a coutume de les appeler au
point de vous valoir l'étiquette
d'avocat des djihadistes c'est une
appellation non contrôlée c'est lourd à
porter surtout que c'est arrivé très tôt
ça
je défendais on va dire une vingtaine de
revenants de Syrie dans les années
2014-2015 et j'ai eu malheur de passer
sur un plateau télévisions d'information
continue avec ils ont fait passer
à Bordeaux avec marqué l'Apocalypse bon
ça m'a étiqueté je sais pas non plus
cracher dans la soupe c'est ce qui est
aussi bon d'une certaine manière
m'a permis de me spécialiser un petit
peu alors non pas dans le djihadisme
mais dans l'association de malfaiteur
justement qu'est-ce qui pousse un
secrétaire de la conférence
autrement dit la crème de la crème du
barreau à se spécialiser dans le terreau
pour reprendre une de vos expressions
c'est une mine de crêpes pour le moins
périlleuse moi je viens de grâce
j'arrive à Paris je connais personne je
connais pas les noms des avocats des
grands avocats donc je suis pas pris
dans les cabinets en stagiaire et je
comprends que le milieu du [__] est un
milieu qui est extrêmement fermé quand
je viens secrétaire de la conférence
alors pour rappeler la Conférence du
stage est une joute oratoire qui
s'accroche chaque année les meilleurs
réteurs du barreau parisien 500
candidats 12 élus trois tours trois
discours comme dans de nouvelles stars
les candidats doivent embarquer le jury
et comme dans la nouvelle star des
inconnus se transforment en Rockstar
pendant un an c'est cette rampe de
lancement qui vous a mis sur orbite oui
parce que je deviens secrétaire de la
conférence en 2013 et 2013 c'est le
moment où tout explose
où les gens commencent à partir en Syrie
[Musique]
ça c'est la première chose
et puis mes copains m'ont laissé un peu
la porte ouverte il voulait pas
forcément y aller et puis je trouve un
intérêt
une satisfaction très rapidement parce
que je rentre dans le monde de
l'idéologie et ça me fait quoi mon
histoire familiale alors justement
est-ce que il faut chercher dans votre
histoire familiale cabossée les racines
de votre engagement oui je pense que
c'est la fusion entre un père et une
mère un père qui portait la robe donc
c'est vers là c'est vers le droit que je
me suis orienté et une mère qui a une
conversion très très puissante et très
forte après la mort de mon père donc une
conversion religieuse donc une
conversion idéologique les deux font que
je suis devenu et pas par hasard je
pense avocat dans dans la matière
idéologique il y a véritablement un sens
parce que vous savez la conversion
de quelqu'un qui vous est proche c'est
quelque chose de pour elle c'est quelque
chose que vous portez aussi qui est pas
simple pour l'entourage ouais pour soi
même aussi puisque c'est
omniprésent dans votre cellule familiale
familiale et donc Dieu si vous voulez
est très présent a été très présent dès
l'âge de 10 ans votre père était juge
d'instruction à Grasse il paraît qu'il
arrivait à votre père de mener ses
interrogatoires avec une grenade à la
main c'est une légende ou c'était
vraiment un trompe la mort c'est pas une
légende puisque c'est son ami qui a été
un moment mon mentor aussi Jean-Pierre
burciano très grand juge d'instruction
capacité toute sa carrière juge
d'instruction à grâce qui a été la mine
de mon père ils étaient ils exerçaient
ensemble et qui qui m'a d'une certaine
manière montré et a pris ce métier là
qui m'a raconté des anecdotes de mon
père parce que c'est très important
quand vous êtes enfant vous l'avez perdu
votre père très tôt on vous raconte des
choses pour pouvoir aller fantasmes et
les imaginer les matérialiser
effectivement il avait il était il avait
ramené de l'armée une grenade et
et en fait il s'en servait juste pour
impressionner quand il interrogé et un
jour il fait descendre son ami
Jean-Pierre gansano de l'étage du dessus
il regarde il a des goupilles et en fait
elle se met à tourner ils se sont barrés
du bureau et tout explosé
tribunal de grande instance de grâce
alors c'est pas pas punk il disparaît
alors qu'il n'a pas 40 ans sans que vous
sachiez à l'époque ni très bien comment
ni pourquoi on évoque une embolie
pulmonaire un suicide aussi vous
découvrirez le fin mot de l'histoire
bien plus tard totalement par hasard
oui j'ai j'avais 9 ans quand il était
mon père est mort quand notre père est
mort et on nous a jamais on a essayé de
nous préserver d'une mort cassé peu de
gens ont compris finalement
parce qu'il avait il avait ses secrets
il avait ses zones de ces zones d'ombres
on savait que qui avait de la drogue qui
l'a consommé mais sans qu'on ne veuille
véritablement le voir et j'ai cherché
moi pendant toute mon adolescence à
essayer de comprendre pourquoi et
comment et c'est par hasard que je
devais faire une vie de médicale pour
pour un job d'été et je tombe sur le
médecin légiste qui par une
faute professionnelle que je pense de se
pardonne toujours pas aujourd'hui il me
dit qu'il a autopié le corps d'un juge
des années des années plus tôt alors le
corps d'un jugement à Grasse si on n'a
pas de on avait qu'un
et donc j'ai exigé de savoir de
connaître les raisons de la mort de mon
père on a compris que c'était en lien
effectivement avec de la prise de la
prise de drogue peut-être aussi avec une
fatigue et psychique et psychologique
qui ont affaibli son organisme au fur et
à mesure il y a pas de causes évidentes
aujourd'hui toujours pas ce qu'on
retient c'est un homme formidable qui
était très aimant pour qui met
énormément ses enfants qui est parti
trop tôt et ça on lui en veut évidemment
parce que c'est compliqué quand
quelqu'un part qui que vous êtes aussi
jeune vous vous retrouvez avec une maman
qui doit tout gérer toute seule et y
compris des violences sexuelles de la
part d'un proche
qui se soldera par une condamnation à 18
ans de religion criminelle votre sœur
dans cette histoire familiale est
devenue commandant de police vous avocat
et votre frère réalisateur ce que l'on
pourrait résumer par cette trinité
l'ordre la justice et la transcendance
ça me plaît beaucoup cette trilogie là
et est-ce que finalement ça n'est pas
totalement à l'image que du couple qui
était celui de mon père et de ma mère
on a eu une succession de effectivement
de drame dans notre famille
mais justement la résilience est un mot
un mois important qui caractérise
l'évolution de ces trois enfants là
parce qu'on n'a jamais voulu se laisser
faire et la réussite de mon frère je la
trouve admirable je suis très en
admiration ma sœur était une personne
incroyable qui est effectivement
aujourd'hui se bat pour des principes
qui sont les siens et qui sont des
principes aussi admirables
la leçon qu'il faut en tirer c'est que
ouais malgré les drames qui
jonchent les parcours de vos vies il
faut continuer à croire en vos idées et
se battre pour arriver à des objectifs
et je trouve que tous les trois
munitions nous y sommes arrivés comme
Hervé Tim ou Eric Dupont-Moretti vous
pensez qu'il faut avoir de grosses
failles narcissiques pour être pénaliste
je pense je pense qu'être pénaliste
effectivement il faut avoir des enfin en
tout cas j'estime moi avoir eu toutes
les avoir toutes les fines narcissiques
parce que effectivement quand vous
perdez quelqu'un jeune vous avez un
besoin de reconnaissance ça c'est
quelque chose qui il y a une sorte
d'incompréhension qui va se traduire en
a besoin de reconnaissance absolue et
vous le trouvez souvent dans des
activités théâtrales vous vous mettez en
avant il faut qu'on me regarde il faut
que la lumière soit sur moi et quel
meilleur métier que le métier d'avocat
pour pouvoir soigner ces failles là
puisque on vous parlez on se tait
ce besoin de reconnaissance absolue qui
est nécessairement liée à la perte de
mon père
je le je réussis à les soigner dans dans
mon activité professionnelle j'aimerais
revenir encore sur le procès des
attentats du Bataclan ce n'est jamais
facile de juger un verdict que dire de
la perpétuité incompressible la sanction
la plus lourde prévue par le droit
français l'ancien garde des Sceaux
Robert Badinter a des taux opposé à une
peine qui équivaut à une mort lente et
vous je suis d'accord je trouve cette
décision extrêmement violente
quel que soit
quel que soit le crime commis la
détention c'est 20 c'est 22h sur 24 dans
une cellule de 9 mètres carrés 22h sur
24 dans des conditions que l'on sait
particulièrement indigne en France c'est
pas moi qui le dis c'est dit c'est dit
par des confrères qui sont des confrères
spécialisés c'est reconnu on est
condamné par la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme 22h sur 24 2 heures
sur 24 quand vous êtes à l'isolement ce
qui est le cas pour la plupart d'entre
eux dans une petite cour avec un
grillage et cela toute votre vie toute
votre vie comment
redescend-t-on mettre nos grasse après
avoir pris part un tel procès
moi j'ai eu besoin de me retrouver dans
ma maison à Grasse qui est notre lieu de
rassemblement familial qui était la
maison de mon père
mais les cigales et l'herbe fraîche et
l'odeur des pins et la pierre ça n'a pas
suffi à
redescendre il y a eu des anémosité il y
a eu des querelles il y a eu des
conflits il y a eu des déceptions avec
ce procès il y a eu plein de choses qui
se sont mélangés c'est le burn-out
c'est le burn out affectivement les
choses vont pas forcément bien vous êtes
vous êtes en colère donc vos relations
avec vos proches de fonctionne pas vous
descendez très très lentement s'il était
dans le noir après ça va il faut refaire
il faut faire des choses il faut il faut
remonter à cheval comme on dit il y a
d'autres procès il y a d'autres clients
ce dans lesquels je suis encore avocat
je vais aller au bout
[Musique]
passionnantes j'aimerais juste conclure
avec cette phrase de maître Jean-Marc de
l'AS la justice est dominé la haine
alors elle a plein de sens cette phrase
la justice c'est dominer la haine c'est
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est déjà pour le juge jugé non pas
avec son ventre
mais avec sa tête parce que jugé avec
son ventre ça donne des décisions
bancale des décisions déséquilibrées et
au final c'est des décisions qui ne
satisfont ni la défense ni les parties
civils
la justice
c'est
peut-être aussi pour les parties civils
c'est savoir pardonner
enfin en tout cas
remettre ce qu'on a en soi entre les
mains de d'une tierce personne qui
donnera juste
la justice c'est dominé la haine quand
on est quand on est avocat c'est c'est
dominer la colère qu'on peut avoir de la
contradiction du contradicteur
qui ne nous comprend pas et estimé que
c'est nous qui avons raison la justice
elle est faite tous ensemble on est là
pour protester quand ça va pas mais
c'est pas systématiquement nous qui
avons raison et eux qui ont tort donc
vous voyez elle est elle est multiface
cette phrase elle est très intelligente
j'aime beaucoup d'ailleurs merci